alors on commence avec eux les tutos de
saint valentin du prince charmant du pcc
cumont car bien sûr alors les deux
derniers un voilà ce sera les deux
derniers qu on aura puisque la savante
ac samedi en fin d'automne pour autre
chose après sa poussette qui reviendra
peut-être peut-être en tout cas ça vous
permet vous le savez de fêter une saint
valentin sans trop dépenser
premier conseil de ce soir comment
trouver des roses à la dernière minute
pour mettre pleins d'étoilés dans les
yeux de votre moitié
tu prends une demi-douzaine de poireaux
un peu de portes rouges je vais sans
valentin chéri bien des tutos de motards
je sais plus ce que c'est
ah oui si vous êtes en couple depuis
longtemps comment recréer le désir chez
votre bien-aimé pour pas cher regarder
je prends la photo de ryan gosling 20
mai sur ta gueule bîmes aphrodisiaques